episode number 99
100 is with whack 100 which will be
coming out
monday friday i don't know
when was it when is it coming out cook
monday
but 99 is here with demrick let's go
and
tony chalk sure
for people who don't know who denmark is
denmark is an incredible emcee and for
people who don't know who tony chalk is
tony chalk is just an all-right beat
maker
damn and you signed him
you're gonna put that out there about
your boy man this is you yo i mean this
you're his manager this is horrible
management it's horrible man it's really
horrible
tony is an alien he's an incredible
producer and uh
my favorite vietnamese person
in the world
god bless you tony this guy put me onto
the best food i've ever had like i've
never i never even [ __ ] with pho
before this guy and he put me on man oh
yeah yeah he invited me over to her for
a korean barbecue at this house
we did get [ __ ] up man but uh listen
so denmark you're here you guys are
putting out mount next week september
15th lessons on the way yeah
um
how was it working like obviously you've
done this before with hapa a few times
right so what was it like doing a whole
project with a producer that wasn't dj
hoppa
i thought it was dope you know tony choc
has a bunch of different like styles of
making beats you know but he has like a
signature sound that kind of like flows
through all that production so the whole
thing was like yo kind of flipping on my
style you know i want to go [ __ ] i could
really spit on and just kind of like you
know i like to get melodic on some
choruses but really i like to go heavy
with the bar work right and so he was
like okay we gonna do it and then you
know he put his twist so some of it's
like trapped but like with hip-hop like
you know he kind of like
would just come to the table with with
song samples that i never heard before
and uh tempos that were always he likes
a lot of up tempo type [ __ ] in my
opinion and that was kind of different
for me because i do you know smoke and
chill music sometimes it gets
introspective and so the fact that he
was keeping the tempos up and [ __ ] like
that i uh i just took it as a challenge
to do something different because i'm
gonna tell you this bro it was it's not
just with dj hopper along the way like
you know i was dropping full projects
with scoopderville i was dropping full
projects even this year alone were you a
part of the get busy committee i wasn't
a part of the get busy committee but i
did a lot of records that was ryu scoop
and apathy yeah and apathy yeah yeah
yeah
yeah no i think uh you know it's a
missing
in hip-hop today the idea of a full
collaborative project with a producer
shout out be real that's what he always
told me about cyprus hill you know he
said that's what gave them the sound was
working with dj mugs and so they was
always about like finding a producer who
you could get in the in the trenches
with you know even originally from my
group tango thoughts i was rapping tech
would do all the beats when i originally
started uh rapping so the way i looked
at it is locking in with somebody
and actually having a meeting of the
minds about the music is how you come up
with the best [ __ ] instead of just and
it's cohesive exactly instead of just
pulling beats from different people uh
this and that day and you know tony
chalk might call me like oh [ __ ] we need
this kind of song now we need we need
this or hey i was doing i flipped this
beat this way hey take a listen to this
now see what you think and you know
actually being in the trenches making a
piece of art you're gonna present for it
it's like good to know that the people
that's doing the music give a [ __ ] just
as much as you do about the content of
the songs how many songs did you guys
cut all together because i know there
was a bunch of didn't make it right yeah
we probably could so there's there's 10
on the hour so i would say we cut maybe
like 17 18 records you know
i'm to the point now with making music
where like a lot of times i won't even
finish the record if i don't feel it
like if that energy doesn't stick with
me you know i'll start something do a
verse in the chorus and i might think
about it the next day bumping it you
know some people that i [ __ ] with let
them hear the music and just kind of sit
with it for a second and say uh maybe
that one's not the one you know what
would be because denmark you've done a
great job of
having a great independent successful
career as a rapper right i think at the
end of the day most artists who are
aspiring to do this [ __ ] all they really
want to do is be able to have a good
living for themselves while doing what
they love right so you've done a great
job of always having music out always
you know being able to
you know do your thing while just doing
what you love right so what what would
be some advice you would give some up
and coming artists
as far as like going into print around
and the things that you've kind of
applied to your career that have made it
sustainable for you to pay your bills
off this rap [ __ ] yeah well i would say
first first off like uh
just the typical way that you you know
because i kind of got on through the
hype man then songwriting and then kind
of doing that and then just as soon as i
was able to just start dropping music
and seeing that i could build fans
through releasing music right i was like
that's all i need to do because i'm not
running out of ideas for versus songs
i'm living every day i'm gaining more
perspective as i've grown if you've seen
anything i've you people who've been
listening to me for a while might be
like damn i kind of seen this [ __ ] grow
up through the music right because i've
been dropping music for so long so
getting consistent is a big part of it
and like don't wait necessarily for the
perfect time to release music or you
know
if you believe in a song release it and
don't get too caught up in the one
record or the one thing you know this is
it you know it's not necessarily that
way for every artist and along the way
one thing's for sure as long as you are
being solid and true within your music
people are gonna gravitate to it and as
you build fan base you know and people
that [ __ ] with you you know you build
power through that and so i just think
about focusing on your fans staying
consistent don't really get caught up
and you know there's a lot of money goes
into this game so you want to have a big
record or things like that you know that
[ __ ]
shut up inside yeah exactly it could
happen on some lottery [ __ ] like but you
can win
the lottery too yeah you know that's one
way yeah but if you want to just drop
some some dope [ __ ] and build with
people you know you got to get in you
got to get smart about how you're going
to do your releases stay consistent and
don't get you know block out the noise
man was that like the goal for you was
just having a core fan base
and then consistently dropping music to
feed them and then watching it kind of
just grow
i think initially i had i was like [ __ ]
i'm finna get it you know uh when i
moved out to l.a it's like [ __ ] i'm
gonna get signing in six months i'm
finna
blow up right
you know but as i started to get in the
game further i would actually see
[ __ ] with one hits one hit
wonder from five years ago or one he'd
wonder from x amount of years ago not
looking like they doing so good
and i started to see some actual [ __ ]
that made me be like you know i really
only thought about
rapping and hustling as my job and what
i was going to do with my life so once i
started seeing people fall off that look
so big to me you know they pulled the
curtain back and i see the way it looked
behind the curtain wasn't necessarily
the way that i thought it but thought it
was gonna be but what i did see
is real people who built real fan bases
didn't really get caught up in the
industry focused on releasing dope [ __ ]
and then building long lasting careers
off of their creativity so i started
thinking like
yeah i want the big hit and the whole
thing about the big hit is that [ __ ] is
still happening out the [ __ ] blue
right you know what i mean there's still
the chance but if you spend all your
time chasing that and you ain't building
you're building a fan base or foundation
to to be sad at the end because life is
hard that's one thing i learned for sure
life's hard the whole way through so you
know what i'm saying if you want to stay
on top of this [ __ ] you got to find what
works for you and go [ __ ] hard for
what you want you have some big homies
in the game you mentioned be real
obviously exhibits uh somebody you know
obviously you guys shout out to the
serial killers projects that are crazy
um
what was like something you took from
each of them as far as helping them on
stage you know because i think the first
time i ever met you was in idaho you
were it was a busy bone be real tour
that was actually the very first tour
that i ever went on would be real yeah
uh and b busy bone didn't show up until
like midnight and then didn't perform
because busy bone i had to pick busy
bone up that night in boise from the
airport in my 92 honda accord and when i
tell you that man was on another planet
he was galactic he was i shot out busy
well he was a man i was like i couldn't
even i didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on yeah crazy
i thought the guy was
possessed in my front step like this
[ __ ] gonna kill me
um but no but like what are the things
you you learned from be real from x as
far as like early on because you know
obviously exhibit's done a great job of
sustaining
you know you know for people who think
that exhibit fell off exhibits a boss
he's a businessman he's [ __ ] pivoted
in so many different ways in this music
industry same thing with be real what
are the things that you kind of learned
from them that right there that for sure
the the ability the ability to look at
opportunities look at the landscape and
get involved in different things you
know and uh not be so one-track minded
but they told me to don't chase sounds
don't try to if you're always trying to
you know be real is like the [ __ ] coming
full circle every time around and why
would i not believe him he'd been in the
game since the beginning of what you
know since
early 89 90 he came in the game and had
a hit record so he's seen [ __ ] come
around a couple times so if he's telling
me you know just stick to the script of
what you [ __ ] with let the game come to
you that was one thing i picked up and
obviously performing with them uh a lot
how to rock a crowd i mean this [ __ ]
like these these ain't club shows with
200 people
i've been on stage with cyprus from the
80 000. you know i've been on stage with
with exhibit in front of 30 40 000 you
know big shows and a bunch of nights in
a row too you know in two years and so
that's kind of the way that i i seen was
big shows big productions real
performance being able to rap perform
your lyrics control the crowd hold it
the [ __ ] down when you're on stage you
are actually entertaining people you got
one hour if you just [ __ ] dancing to
your own songs the whole [ __ ] time
you know that [ __ ] gonna get old quick
yes that when i say when that when that
hits start dying down then the show
stopped they stopped the booking stopped
coming because you didn't really pay
attention to the performance aspect of
the game and everything so i learned so
much [ __ ] from
from them that it's it's kind of hard uh
i was actually watching something and
they were talking about mentors and i
really am like damn you know i really
have some dope ass mentors in my life
you know be real
and exhibit and that i started out from
one to rap for those dudes to hype man
and for them to do songs with them to
doing albums with them and a
long-standing relationship that still
goes to this day so that means what does
that mean it means you didn't [ __ ] it up
you didn't drop the ball you didn't get
too big-headed you stayed solid and
that's one of the things it's hard to
get a big head when you see people that
have done it so big for so long and see
that they still grinding every day they
still going for it every day but i see
what it means to the people and what it
means to them and how they present it so
stay solid man and i'm lucky that i have
mentors like that yeah when you talk
about the performance i think that one
of the things that kind of showed
through was that versus battle with the
locks and yeah it was like
them dudes was not rapping over their
lyrics they wasn't ready it was rocking
seriously that was rocking the crowd and
dipset didn't take it seriously yeah at
least i'm not saying they didn't take it
all the way serious but obviously
there's a difference between
you know did i feel like dipset's peak
happened after the locks really started
to come into the game even though cam
was around during the same time the
locks came in but like the dip set wave
really hit like
i always think of like 2001 2002 and you
think of the locks
late 90s you know 97 98 and just kind of
like the different eras of like
performing like yeah not over your own
lyrics yeah exactly tracks and and
that's what i say when when i said they
weren't prepared i wasn't saying in the
in the
the whole [ __ ] but as far as like
rapping yeah like to be able to just
throw on a beat
like who shot you and then jada know his
who shot your freestyle from and then
just and rip it for two minutes straight
yeah exactly and talk [ __ ] be funny be
charismatic uh hold it down and actually
delivering full verses all the way
through you know and that that [ __ ] is
that it takes time you gotta hone your
craft on that level to be able to do
that you know it's
you started however you started i feel
like nowadays [ __ ] don't even
they just start like basically in the
room with the homies you know just
making songs on the computer you know i
think when i started it was more like
you know you was rapping in a cipher or
some [ __ ] like that you know but it's it
remains the same it starts from a very
minimal place and as it builds up you
got to look at all of what hip-hop is
about and everything and figure out what
you want to participate in and what you
want to focus in but if you want to do
the whole [ __ ]
performing is a part of it you know what
i mean and rapping
truly rapping that's it man hey what up
man we got to interrupt the interview
real quick to tell you about our family
at odd socks now when i be riding for
odd socks so hard man it's because i
really love the product they got the
most comfortable socks in the [ __ ]
world i got a pair of odd socks basics
on right now go get those they got the
socks wwe joints you know i'm saying
shout out to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddsoxofficial.com you'll save 20 off
underwear the most comfortable socks in
the world crazy licenses not only they
got the ww they got the scarface they
got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview tony chuck
so uh you did a whole album with kasky
fine art right which is fire thank you
uh what was the difference between
working with caskey and denmark on a
whole project together
talking to the microphone you [ __ ] you
um the difference is
kathy's worked way too fast and i try to
keep up with him
but
um
i don't know it it's a whole different
environment like i've learned a lot from
working with katkin and and working with
denmark um
denver kind of slowed me down a little
bit and made me stinks more and you know
be creative right and with caskey he was
like yo let's go let's go let's go pull
him up and then and i go back and fix
stuff
right so
yeah so what denmark is like you take
your time do it right the first go round
and right yeah yeah yeah so so i learned
my pace for what certain artists yeah
what was your guys's like uh if you had
to pick a record one record off of
blessings on on on by the way the title
track's my favorite but
uh what's your guys's favorite record on
that i like stew
yeah i like steel that's one of my
favorite as well um
i would but i like the intro i see that
blessings on the way
what i feel like that record is like
something that's connecting with a lot
of people a lot of people are feeling it
right now with everything that's been
going like an anthem bro yeah exactly
and it's like it's a song that speaks to
a lot of people you know it it was
written
in a in a form that's kind of like for
everybody you know what i mean blessings
on the way who out here you know we're
in there everybody grinding getting to
it everybody's bl everybody's going hard
for that [ __ ] everybody is seeing you
know knocking [ __ ] off they list one
step at a time so that's what it is
blessings on the way embodies that so
what do you um you know with the
pandemic obviously i don't even know if
we're on the other side of it yet but
like first i know you depend a lot on
the live shows right like how did that
kind of make you rethink things or maybe
make you pivot differently in 2020. i
think um
i'm assuming you were going to be on
tour i was going to be on tour and what
happened is like uh because you know
shout out uh this because we did we
during the pandemic that you know what
you guys just did the critical shows
right you had to cancel one though right
yeah we canceled one because that whole
thing they wanted us to make an
announcement for people to get
vaccinated or or show up with the with
the negative tests and now i feel like
that's kind of the norm but when they
wanted us to to say it it was kind of
like i don't know if we want to like you
know really put that out there like that
so yeah we canceled one show but the
other show was good but what i'm saying
is basically during when covey hit it
gave me a chance to sit at home and say
hey number one i'ma make more music
i'ma drop more [ __ ] i'ma double down
with putting things out online and
things like that and really get projects
like the one with tony choc dunn like me
and uh exhibit b real did another serial
killers album me and dizzy did ablaze
with us too during that year yeah that's
real me i dropped a lot of i dropped the
line through 1500 nothing
i dropped me and mike and keith keys
dropped championship rounds and uh so
just a lot of music that i put out and i
got a shout out reezy because we we
dropped the album called payday so i
dropped so much music in the last uh
couple years of this [ __ ] because now
we're looking at the pandemic [ __ ]
almost been around
a year and a half
yeah yeah
march right two years of march and it's
crazy uh i was and how i know that is
because i was on stage
me and bernard and larry june we did
four shows right before the cove yeah it
was all they were on cali right yeah
exactly and me and bernard we was on
stage you know because i go up on stage
and do xanax and patrol whatever we was
we was doing the [ __ ] the shoulder
[ __ ] you know instead of doing it you
know because it was kind of like we
didn't really know what was gonna happen
so uh
of course everything locked down and i
said [ __ ] let me double down on on these
businesses you know let me let me figure
out you know stony point the cannabis
brand you know let me figure out uh
the gasco mac tonight you know let me
figure out this merch situation let me
figure out uh we just dropped a beer
stoney juice that we dropped uh me and
hoppa
with a company called uh 405 north
brewing
and um you know you just kind of double
down kings you know on the side [ __ ] in
the catalog yeah exactly and but it's
it's about kind of like cultivating
these other little business ideas and
seeing where they could grow to you know
obviously being in the cannabis market
is something that i feel like a lot of
people
want to do but right now but a lot of
people can't really get in on a real
level and so i had the opportunity to
really be involved with it so the thing
is it's like how hard do i want to go
for it you know how big do i want to
push it to be right yeah i think that's
the thing a lot of rappers will get into
the weed game and they think that like
you just get a strain and that's where
it stops
and like the weeds gonna sell itself
yeah it's like bro you really gotta work
as hard if you really wanna pop off in
the weed game because it's so comp
competition's almost as crazy i mean
it's not as crazy as the rap game but
it's up there yeah i mean there's so
much weed especially in cali so much how
do you how are you gonna
separate yourself from the pack not even
just quality wise just branding wise
just like you know so i think that's
another thing like with the weed game
it's like
there's artists who might might not be
as like i guarantee you there's bigger
artists that have weed strains that
aren't even touching how successful your
wheat strain is you know yeah and that's
what they should they be giving we
strains and [ __ ] that some people don't
even smoke weed you know what i'm saying
they're doing it they do it
literally jay-z yeah
shout out to hove hov is just
historically not a pot guy
yeah i don't remember uh you know you
know you know shout out to my guy g eazy
he just launched flower shop never was a
big weed guy i mean he's been smoking
more recently but he was somebody who
wasn't like a big weed guy you know
exactly but you look like someone like
dizzy who's obviously
yo dizzy [ __ ] gotta go because people
are gonna be like if it's dizzy right
[ __ ] i'm a smoker cause i know he's a
smoker exactly and it's like
understanding that we actually met with
the breeders built with them perfect
examples
right yeah of course right burner's got
the biggest wheat [ __ ] and like if you
think a burner is like a rapper like
there might be bigger rappers in the
space but burners
all in
exactly from the jump is what i'm saying
so yeah and i think it's uh it's dope to
see the stony point [ __ ] going crazy so
that's it besides uh blessings on the
way
we got a like four or five more months
left in the year anything else you're
gonna be dropping uh
right after this right after blessings
on the way which drops september 15th
you got to check this out it's fire yeah
what is that on um
thursday wednesday that's a wednesday i
think it's a wednesday wednesday because
friday's the 17th right yeah and then um
stony point three with me and hopper's
about to drop
so we got that next and it's completely
recorded and ready and then me and jared
benton going in the year with an ep
together so
that'll be fire that's said bars man
having fun with it you know just talking
our [ __ ] you know i think at this point
that
i like what i see with a lot of rappers
that are out there right now getting to
love i really love what benny the
butcher and and all zelda's doing i love
what uh you know i like to see freddie
gibbs you know somebody that i consider
to be around
the whole time i've been around yeah
grinding and see where he's sitting
right now and just seeing rappers really
stick into their guns and getting what
they deserve but like you said almost
like uh what be real told you like let
the game come to you exactly well so
that's what those guys did yep so as far
as the lyrical [ __ ] and just talking on
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] ain't going away as
long as i keep experiencing it i must
keep on bringing it to the table hey
tony what advice would you give upcoming
up and coming producers
don't give up
doesn't matter what type of beat you
make just don't give up
don't give up don't give up
why do you say that have you been have
you been around for a while
i mean this multiple time i want to give
up but
how long have you been making beats tony
he's in high school how old are you 36.
damn you [ __ ] old as [ __ ] bruh
bro i'm just [ __ ] with you tony bro
you're like behind me i know but i'm
just saying
bro y'all asian [ __ ] aged so
well
how old do i look you look like you're
about 27. i think so yeah
hey man black don't crack and asian
people don't age that's it man
facts shout out to all the eight so
listen so don't give up
what this is what i want to say about
tony chagan his production is i feel
like he was the person that when i was
going out to arizona uh they would
always say hey you got to get with this
producer named tony choc like he really
got that [ __ ] and he came to the studio
a couple times and i don't think you
ever had an opportunity to really press
play no no
yeah it's you know it's the weirdest
yeah weird but the way that it actually
worked out is you grinded you ended up
signing with
with bootleg i convinced his ass to move
out here to move to l.a and it's like by
the time i see you in the studio right
here i realized that the hunger would it
wouldn't be denied you know it's just
like you
every day making beasts i follow you on
social media i see you consistently
working i'm like see when you that
hungry and you got that much talent it's
timing and it's actually getting in the
mix and putting the work in and that's
one of the hardest working producers
that i for sure that i met you know and
uh he'd be running from one session to
the to the i'm coming
and you know i work hard so i'm like
this this dude going crazy and the fact
that
because it was really you who who was
like yo y'all got to make this ep happen
you know so i'd have a feeling like for
people out there that haven't heard of
his production like it's a lot of big
records a lot of music a lot of
foundation and groundwork being laid in
and it's only a matter of time before
everybody's gonna want a project with
him
it's gonna be on everybody's [ __ ] that's
it perry there it is man hopefully
hopefully it's coming to this guy though
he um
for everyone who doesn't know i bust
this guy's balls always not just while
the cameras are roaming
got to keep them humble man got to keep
them home yo what the [ __ ] that man the
[ __ ] yeah i didn't know how racist that
would be if i'm being honest i was going
to try to i was going to try
i was gonna try to get pho brought in
for the interview but i figured that
might be a little
knocking on racism door i asked him
yesterday he was like
he's like nah we're good i love pho
but you know i just don't know man i
don't i don't want to get canceled
online
a vietnamese producer's interview
and he's cancelled
well listen man the album is out
september 15th that's next wednesday uh
this will be out friday so
five days away uh and uh
there's a few there's three or four
songs out right now yeah four songs
right yeah yeah there's four records out
ritz record just dropped which is doing
really well i saw yeah um
uh
paul wall that record's out a little
money and that's the beans dizzy record
yeah
and then what was the what was that the
one with the lexus and the oh yeah the
sexton kid right
right from mine there it is go go
support demrik tony chuck
shout out to uh don't we have a um
release party coming up
arizona monarch on the 29th of september
let's go phoenix
get your tickets they're only ten
dollars it's easy all right pull up man
if you're in arizona a lot of people in
arizona watch this so come come the
[ __ ] arm release party tony will make
a beat live on stage he's going to bring
his [ __ ] ableton push
let's get it all right there it is boom